[Musik]
nein
das rating buy
ich danke festzugs person wo innert 24
stunden am tag dass ich da so mit wenig
drin ist zur neige gehen versuchen eine
geborgenheit und sicherheit im alltag
aber mit in den medien der mobilität im
alltag frei und das danke ich den
schwierig für kind wenn sie jeden tag
garantiert und wenn sie es gerne berühmt
und 20 minuten vermissen die handwerker
nicht so gut weil ich meine ich gern
zahlten dauer und anhaltende gewalt
suchtkrankheit es gibt verschiedenste
gründe die es eltern verunmöglichen für
ihre kinder zu sorgen
deshalb kümmern sich nicht mami und papi
sondern eben bezugspersonen wie martina
kirchhof um die kleinen kann das
gelingen oder bleiben zwangsläufig
narben zurück davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
hierher führt immer ein notfall die
kinder die in kinderhaus zu wohnen
stammen aus schwierigsten verhältnissen
ihr zuhause ist zerrüttet und eine
lösung dringend im tipi bekommen sie ein
vorübergehendes geheim hier bleiben sie
in der regel wenige tage bis höchstens
ein paar monate danach sollen sie zurück
zu den eltern oder in eine pflegefamilie
im obersten stock leben die kleinsten
das älteste wird heute in der zeit in
der sie hier wohnen sollen sich die
kinder so geborgen fühlen wie möglich
geburtstag feiern ohne eltern auf das
ist das heim zuständig das
geburtstagskind kennt es nicht anders
die zweijährige hat fast ihr ganzes
leben hier im heim verbracht die mutter
ist psychisch krank der vater im ausland
alle paar wochen ein anruf mehr kontakt
zu den eltern besteht nicht
das tipi ist evers zu hause
so manches hat man ihnen vorenthalten in
ihrem kurzen leben ihr recht auf
anonymität wollen wir waren und zeigen
deshalb die gesichter der kinder nicht
unter martina schützlingen sind auch
neugeborene für viele ist das heim das
erste zu hause wenn mütter während der
schwangerschaft drogen nahmen beginnt
das leben mit einem entzug direkt nach
der geburt martina holt im kinderspital
einen säugling ab die dem fall ist ja
jetzt wie warum sollte das mit einfacher
zu ihnen bringen
sie habe mit den sagt immer begleiterin
so einen transporter ich lerne ich etwas
was passiert unterwegs an sieg nur kurz
nach 1 uhr kunden wachsen das hat sie
mit dem stehen bisher schon vorher mit
dem streamen einfach begleiten und dann
kannst du selbst fand aber tragen und
alles aber dafür verwies dass seine
mutter ihre eigenen kinder tötet kommt
äußerst selten vor dass polizei jetzt
mutter verhaftet sie steht im dringenden
tatverdacht noch diesjährigen
erkenntnissen spielte sich aber genau
eine solche tragödie gestern abend im
zürcherischen flach ab vor einem jahr
erschütterte die verzweiflungstat einer
mutter die schweiz
sie brachte ihre beiden kleinen kinder
um damit sie nicht zurück ins kinderheim
mussten die heim platzierung als
schlimmstes möglichkeit schlimmer als
der tod
ein extremfall trotzdem dass das eigene
kind ins heim muss ertragen eltern nur
schwer
[Musik]
das weiß man auch im tipi dass ich
lieber kinderhaus als kinderheim nennt
stefan germann sohn ist der leiter hier
ein erfahrener psychologin
wir sind in der schweiz eher historisch
belastet mit dem begriff vor der herr im
anzug auf viele jahrzehnte wo man die
armut betroffen
mancher und auch kein verfahren de facto
hat immer andere vorstellungen hat wird
ihn zur wache wo man drin die kirche hin
zu den älteren und weniger
berücksichtigt hat wir vielleicht über
kite und ordentlichkeit wichtig ist ob
er gehörte zu denen die einfach billiger
bisher sehr wichtig und tracht vom kind
mit den eigenen eltern aufwachsen ist
hoch
die frage zielt darauf ab was ist dann
größer da schaut altersheim oder das
schaut sieht ua zion was kind vorher in
kitsch und schmalz ziel sie das bedeutet
das heim eine unterstützung bildet eine
who froze darstellt zum tausch von
vorlag wurde nicht gut vertragen und
überwinde mit einer der satz um resident
so der widerstandsfähigkeit aufbau aber
das ist der auftrag und sinn und zweck
von meiner heimat teilen dass eine
metallbox abschaffen und schließe die
heime schließen das steht außer frage
heime mit so fortführen und den kindern
ein zuhause und geborgenheit anbieten
das haben sich martina und ihre
kolleginnen zum ziel gesetzt es steht
ein abschied bevor ein geschwisterpaar
kann das heim verlassen und zurück zur
mutter
die betreuerinnen legen auch bei den
jüngsten großen wert auf eine abschieds
ritualen internetseiten transportiert
sie das alles passiert am 4
aber ich denke jetzt ausgepackt ist es
nötig statt
hier wollen wir mit dem muss mit
aufgeschnittener haft befinden
wie machen wir das ja wieder ein erfolg
wertet bitte unter beschwerden an die
zukunft baut aber wenn ich weiß dass ich
eines kurt krömer dass wir mit dem ami
die familie zudem finde ich sehr schön
wenn sie krank und eine note mit wo muss
ich halt dass konstanz umfallen konstant
sie bezugspersonen die zinsen blieben
bisschen situation musizieren ich geb
dir mit den worten oh ja das gefühl
hatten dass sie wir machen da es in
völliger was man gut findet aber
vielleicht miteinander chatten
[Musik]
die mitarbeitenden sollen sich israel
aus und braucht bindung zu den personen
wo das schafft es die haie für das ist
grundlage für alle weiteren
entwicklungsprozess dem kind laufes
seines förderers liebte da und das ist
nun möglich wenn sich die high und
gebohrt gefühlt so zuerst auch in einer
inneren institution auspackt hat was ich
unterscheidet von monika haget
ermöglicht rot mbh
ich treffe kassandra und liu die beiden
haben mit sämtlichen stationen einer
drogenkarriere bekanntschaft gemacht
auf der straße gelebt im gefängnis
gesessen den schulabschluss verpasst und
dann wurde cassandra schwanger
therapie zu machen
die drohung war klar würden sich die
eltern nicht auf die therapie einlassen
nehme man ihnen die tochter weg
undenkbar für die 2 aber das bedeutete
erstmal einen heroinentzug die
umstellung auf methadon und fortan lebte
die kleine familie nicht mehr
selbstständig wurde engmaschig
kontrolliert vor allem mit blick auf das
wohl der tochter täglich zukunft die
gleiche verhalten zu machen vielleicht
zu bauen dann krisenerfahrung vielleicht
gewiss nicht genug für zelten und auf
altes bewahren
aber ich glaube ich weiß alles besser
schon jetzt schon bescheid
befindlichkeit darum wer das ist so
schlimm sie die gedanken tochter im heim
zwischen langenhain vergangenheit
und 12
so vielseitig doch das runde dazu und
ich bin ein ich muss dich heute musst du
sowieso dem schwere frage gestellt wieso
ist dabei aber dass die ursache konnte
dann verletzt später musste frage
wichtig sei wieso hat mir kraft
irgendwie als kassandra schwanger war
glaubten die zwei noch die situation
allein ohne hilfe von außen bewältigen
zu können und wagten einen ersten
schritt in richtung bürgerliches leben
hochzeit in weiß künstlich werden das
wäre ein traum sagen sie mir die
erinnerungen an eine verkorkste jugend
im heim vergessen was läuft
kinder betreut werden
ja das ist natürlich ein unterschied ob
das kinderheim
sie haben vieles versucht in ihrem leben
und wohl häufig die falsche entscheidung
getroffen
ich wünsche ihnen dass es diesmal die
richtige war zwölf jahre seiner kindheit
verbrachte livio im heim weggesperrt als
sechsjähriger undenkbar heute glaube ich
und mache mich auf zu claudia tobler die
sozialarbeiterin nimmt zurzeit 30
beistandschaften war
sie lassen sich bei ihren entscheidungen
vom kindswohl leiten sagt sie was ist
das denn das kindswohl will ich wissen
will
leider ist es nicht immer möglich dass
sie im griff und wohnen das heißt aber
nicht dass man muss der kontakte jeden
fall ganz abbrach ich danken kapital es
ist ganz wichtig banken platziert sind
dort eltern über im kontakt liefert das
bedingt dass die eltern gewählt sind mit
dem heim zusammenzuarbeiten
die pädagoginnen geben ihr bestes kein
zweifel die mahlzeiten sind gesund die
umgebung kindgerecht trotzdem frage ich
mich reicht dieses professionell
tadellose umfeld um die geschichten
dieser kinder diese geschichten von
gewalt vernachlässigung und übergriffen
in den hintergrund treten zu lassen
die beiständin spricht aus was eine
unangenehme wahrheit ist kinder müssen
auch vor ihren eltern geschützt werden
häufige deine frage warum ist antonio
bis gemacht wurde muss man eben eine
frage hatten irgendwie ist gemeldet dann
werde selber nachgemeldet
ich bin so lieber einmal zu viel als
einmal zu wenig aber anders vielleicht
so der schweizer mentalität entspricht
und mehr chemie gehabt privatpersonen
und ich war nach wenigen aktionen aber
die ich schon dass man unbedingt will es
wäre also je nach alter halt die sind je
nach der situation was ausgerichtet sind
und ich würde es sehr begrüßen wenn da
bei mathematik gehört werden
diesbezüglich
was hilft was hilft den kindern und was
hilft den pädagoginnen die arbeit mit
den kleinen ist intensiv und fordernd
ein austausch unter der leitung einer
supervisorin gehört deshalb fest ins
programm kind kriegt mitternachts und
schmiere an körper und wänden und wc
das wäre einfach so ist es auch klar
warum es macht nicht verstanden vorher
war einfach mal schreibt und ich damit
rauskommen wenn es saalbach hilflos
fühlen in der situation wenn auch wonach
die gefühle oder wenn am gurt merck kgaa
will be on certain sache ist gelöst und
ein bisschen sorgen zu machen dann
ludwigsburg ihr ja also vom jesus als ob
mein gott ich gesammelt und nach toni
wieder energie wachsen und industrie
gemacht dann und schreibt und so um sich
schlott in feste also herbert und
irgendeine die körperspannung zusammen
und den hunter wenn es hilfen
aber das ist also das muss man also ist
der schmuck macht das missionshaus st
das lockt traditionell im moment kostet
das gemeinschaftsgefühl dass ein umzug
fleck familie drei tagen ab seite weil
die flag familie merkte dass sie nicht
die richtige sind und das telefon den
gegner und dann halt gemerkt wie es mir
selber so schwer wird und hat ein jahr
gemerkt ich muss das dem kind ja hinter
sich und will sie ihm aber auch so sehr
dass ihr vorher für mich wegen so etwas
schon der gute teil trat gibt es auch
was gutes dass es jetzt ab zeit woche
ist damit es nicht so schwer ist und
dann wie sage ich es ihm
ich habe mir vorstellen dass da was dran
empfinde ich das so abgrenzungsprobleme
sicher zu sein dass die hier viele
traurige schicksal und so netzwerk habe
dass lehrer ja aber durch supervision
also dass lehrer sind ausbildung oder
das ist schon ein thema und es ist
einfach im rang zwei vor
was passiert wäre jetzt und ihre
situation und wir können wir jetzt dem
kind die bestmögliche unterstützung
agierte jetzt muss es der fachlicher
sicht und nicht so verschmelzen wurde
und ich muss dir jetzt halfen oder
sondern so datei muss man auch darüber
nachdenken was ist der mini motivation
jetzt mit dem wasser mit so kinder
schaffe ihr beruf verlangt ihnen viel ab
die kinder begnügen sich nicht mit
professioneller distanz sie suchen das
was ihnen zustünde wärme liebe beziehung
gleichzeitig geraten die betreuerinnen
immer wieder in die schusslinie zwischen
behörden und eltern das prägt
[Gelächter]
dass ich mir das stück wenn ihr beruf
offenbart beklemmung und lebt toleranz
irgendwo dazwischen keimt die hoffnung
so stammend so abgründig wieso macht im
anschluss auch das eine untersetzung mit
was ist böse und wieso gibts das
angezeigt sich das kommende jahr machen
sind vor jahrzehnten motiv sitzung auf
psychologie studieren zu meedia bediene
und hoffen nicht damals ich natürlich so
dass ich einen beitrag leisten dass es
möglicherweise gar nicht gibt und so
abgründigen und zerstörerische speziell
gegenüber was ich nun können wären und
zwar zu tisch wenn ich bald als ganzes
ideologen und situation vor durch
indirekte internationalen tennis alte so
dramatisch wie jetzt sind wir seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg so viele flüchtlinge
dass autos erschüttern mich immer wieder
im bild festhalten dass ich eine
einfache lösungen und szene man mich
halt immer wieder zu bescheidenheit und
zeigen in kleine bootstour da für dich
hin wo da sind und die familie ist er
ist möglich wirken und uns halten wir
begrenzt dass ich tatsächlich wirken und
die wirtschaft ist der tägliche aufgabe
gutes tun im kleinen diese kinder danken
es sie denen nur solche einrichtungen
einen halbwegs behutsamen start ins
leben bieten können
[Musik]
java ist das so